Hey guys,
Nikita and I were just at a
fuel station, filled up the car.
And there was someone there and we
started the conversation with him.
And I asked him, do you love Jesus Christ?
And he shared with us something terrible
that just happened to him and that he's struggling
with something and that his two kids - the one is
in the hospital the other one was just attacked
- hand cut off - and the tears started to flow.
And we talked to him a little bit and I felt that
the Holy Spirit led us to be there at this time
for this person who is also called Daniel.
So I want to remind you to not just
be so self-absorbing in your own bubble.
There are people out there that need your light.
You need to share the Gospel.
Be the light.
And listen to the Holy Spirit so that when
people need you - need God - but God working
through you - then you are there for them.
Love other people as you love yourself.